If we show you a random shape, your eyes
will send the information to your brain
which will then decide what to
do with it - perhaps not much.
If we show you another shape, your
senses will again send it to your brain,
but now it might be able to find some related
information that was stored in your memory.
You may have forgotten, but when you
were young, you knew nothing. The
first time you saw a particular shape, it was
meaningless. Over time and in search for order,
you started to recognize patterns. One day
someone gave that particular thing meaning,
your mind labeled it as important and
decided to store it for future use.
So next time you see this or that shape,
you might want to pause and pay tribute
to the fact that there are more connections
in your brain than stars in the universe,
here to help you organize inputs, thoughts
and memories to get you through life.